last week British voters went to the
polls to vote in the European Union
elections and the results were a big
victory for the brand-new brexit party
brexit party demands a very simple thing
that the British government honor the
2016 referendum to leave the EU Britain
was already supposed to be out of the EU
months ago but the people in charge have
dragged their feet and are now demanding
a second vote as in the United States
democracy is only welcomed when it
confirms the policies chosen by people
in power in case you haven't noticed
Nigel Faraj leads the brexit party and
he joins us tonight
Nigel Fox thanks very much for coming on
congratulations and if you would Chris
plea for our American audience explain
why three years after brexit the UK is
still in the EU yeah we voted in a
referendum to leave the European Union
the greatest democratic exercise the
most voters ever in the history of our
nation we then the next year in a
general election voted for labour and
conservative passes our traditional
parties both of whom promised they would
honor the result of the referendum and
the date was set it was put into British
law we were leaving on March 29th 2019
and guess what happened we didn't leave
and they kicked the can down the road to
the end of October the 31st of October
Halloween and I watched all of this has
been one of the architects of the
original brexit referendum and vote and
I thought I can't stand aside I can't
bear the fact we're having to send
members of the European Parliament back
to Brussels so I found it the brexit
party and would you believe within six
weeks of a brand new party being set up
we topped the polls we smashed the
Conservative Party we smashed the Labour
Party and regrettably I'm back here in
Brussels Tucker
after 20 years once again as a member of
the European Parliament now I know it's
complicated but explain if you can how
it is a liberal or progressive position
to remain in the German Empire which is
basically what the EU is why is that
considered liberal because they claim
that as a European Union they will deal
with climate change
they claim that because they have open
borders this is the modern liberal
approach to the future what they don't
tell you is they are literally killing
and destroying something something so
important that just next week we're
going to celebrate the 75th anniversary
of d-day when America and Canada and
others came to our aid helped us
liberate you know Europe from Nazism to
bring back something called democracy
and what the European Union does it
crushes democracy it takes
decision-making powers away from
ordinary people and gives it to other
elected bureaucrats right well that the
head of the European Commission doesn't
appear to be cutting you any slack
there's a quote a remarkable quote just
the other day which doubtless you saw it
I'm quoting now these stupid
nationalists he said they are in love
with their own countries it doesn't
sound like people like this have learned
anything from these votes no no this is
mr. Uecker who is president of the
European Commission that's his quote but
you know the people I blame aren't
necessarily the brussels bureaucrats the
people i blame are British politicians
in Westminster who have not had the
courage to take back the independence
sovereignty democracy of our country
last week I've given them the biggest
seismic shock that has been seen in
modern British politics and I'll make
you this one promise if we do not leave
the European Union on October the 31st I
will lead the brexit party after that
into the next general election and we
will sweep away passes that are
dominated British politics for over a
hundred years we could be talking to the
next Prime Minister of Great Britain
Nigel Frost
thank you very much for joining us
tonight and good luck thank you